the real meaning of the name Antarctica
kind of blew my mind okay so the first
part ant is sort of like anti just means
sort of opposite but Arctica means bear
okay so Antarctica literally means like
opposite of the bear so obviously
there's no bears in Antarctica by the
way and no it has nothing to do with
polar bears being in the Arctic or the
North it has to do with the Stars
there's this one constellation that most
of us know as the Big Dipper but
Civilizations for a lot of years looked
up at the stars and saw this as a bear
Ursa Major Sailors and Navigators always
use this constellation to find the North
Star Polaris the way I always thought
about it is like the Dipper of the Big
Dipper kind of points to Polaris that's
North okay so for a lot of people this
big dipper that kind of looks like a
bear up in the sky is sort of synonymous
with North and so that's how we get
Antarctica that's the opposite of the
bear the bear is north and the opposite
of the north bear is the South the South
Pole Antarctica